I have good news for Slovenia the
commission has decided that Slovenia can
receive this first payment of around 50
million euros from Next Generation EU
this is the result of good progress in
the implementation of the slovene
recovery plan
you adopted a national plan for the
transformation of the economy
Next Generation EU will help slovene
businesses for example go digital
this makes Slovenia an even more
attractive place for investment
you are facilitating access to funding
in particular for green Investments
you're making public procurement
procedures leaner and more transparent
and you're cutting red tape for
businesses
so this all goes in the right direction
and I also welcome the important steps
taken towards a long-term care reform
for the benefit of the most vulnerable
so good progress as you see
but it's just the beginning Slovenia is
set to receive over 2.2 billion euros
as it rolls out further reforms and
Investments
keep up the good works Slovenia and we
stand right by your side as you roll out
your plan under Next Generation EU